elect me prime minister leader the race
is on to find the next Tory leader and
prime minister but I'm running to be our
next prime minister and I'm the person
to deliver that you'll be for
conservative MPS and members to make
that decision so what are they looking
for and what are the issues that could
affect who makes it to Downing Street
right from the start tax has been a
major battle line let's cut the tax
operation tax it just matters that's
because there's lots of Tories that are
unhappy with recent tax hikes to pay for
things like Health after the pandemic
and social care candidates have pledged
to reverse April's National Insurance
rise and cut business taxes and income
tax if elected the exception is former
Chancellor issue sunak who wants to
focus on balancing the books before
looking to then reduce taxation it's
true that generally Tories like tax cuts
but those voting in this contest need to
believe that the promises are realistic
that's why unfunded or unsustainable
pitches could backfire
Rising energy bills petrol prices and
food costs are set to be the biggest
issue in the new prime minister's in
tray so you can expect a lot of focus on
that too candidates will argue that tax
cuts will help with the cost of living
and others think that they won't be
focused enough on the most vulnerable
with economists warning that tax cuts
actually leave less money for the
government to spend on helping people
directly the cost of filling up at the
pump is a classic issue for Tory
leadership races but promises to slash
tax on fuel won't sit well with
environmental commitments foreign
Boris Johnson through his time in office
fine for breaking lockdown rules accused
of lying about the actions of his MPS
and persistent questions around
donations money and gifts that means
integrity and truthfulness matter a lot
in this contest contenders that are seen
as too close to Boris Johnson may be
disadvantaged that said accusations of
disloyalty and stabbing the current
prime minister in the back might not go
down well with some Tory members
previous business dealings and tax
Affairs will also be put under the
microscope with some contenders already
promising to publish their accounts that
I will publish my accounts annually my
tax returns annual
brexit will probably matter less now
than it has in previous contests but
previous remain and leave allegiances
still run deep especially when there are
issues left to solve with the EU with
Northern Ireland still the thorniest
area candidates will be grilled on how
they would solve this issue and whether
they would keep controversial
legislation which many say breaks into
National Law so those are some of the
big issues but this race will
undoubtedly take unexpected turns
there'll be scandals dirty tricks and
attempts to try and knock out some of
the big candidates before Tory members
even get to vote conservative leadership
races are not known for being gentle
affairs